various anything is happening gentleman
right now on to touch chat which is that
also right now there are some news
coming out of GDC about Sony's
PlayStation VR okay previously known
about as the Morpheus the problem is so
you can never tell if the chat stun
truth is all this [ __ ] like I'm like
looking at you can see me probably all
time just like chicken and corn being I
and someone's like saying oh yeah three
hundred ninety nine dollars yeah and
that coming ash can we just check the
clicks into bhakta well yeah we're widow
for something right yeah yeah especially
today apparently today apparently
sometime I think they're having a press
conference down the road and then like
they're not live streaming I don't think
I think it's just like they're having us
and then the embargo drops and then
we'll know stuff where do we know the
price yup 399 kashyap I just got on the
twitters but thank you Mary very much
voice of God Marrakech 400 bucks on what
was in October 2016 alright cool called
it sweet for in G books I mean holiday I
talk good money was on 400 yeah yeah
Arnie late ad I knew it they had to go
lower to try to you know compete that's
how I felt at least October Baby right
ready for Christmas outside yeah
although I didn't dig its it would be
what like seven though huh cuz you have
to count the console if you don't only
on the console man if you wanna console
by I can oculus rift ya know live or
viral we're all about the buy of now
right at least right now those yet
because we had the Viper this room we're
getting our don't talk to him to the kid
gears okay I don't buy a samsung phone
by the SN and we've got a free everyone
I so okay who here on the base station
for all three of us soon okay 400 bucks
airtight will you buy a playstation vr
no now at least not right away I think I
think with this kind of technology i'm
going to do the wait-and-see approach
right and kind of gauge you know which
one I like the best what has the best
application software games what not and
you know luckily fortunately for us we
do have ways to try that stuff out so
that will give me an advantage of like
okay I want to you know do that or I
don't want to do that so that's what I'm
gonna do I don't know what about you
Mike
if you'd asked me six months ago I would
have said probably not I it took me
forever to get on the VR train but then
bang since then I've gone to a bunch of
events i played a bunch of games like
shoot you full on 400 sounds sounds fine
I'll do it yeah I mean I did I feel like
it's been a while since i bought a ps4
so it doesn't feel like it's not much of
a yeah you know it was a couple years
ago so it's not too crazy one of the
things I'm really happy about what's
happening and you notice a lot of
something like GDC is that like making
VR games is super dangerous because the
install base of any one of these is
really low but everyone's spreading the
risk it seems like everything that's
coming out on PlayStation VR is also
coming out on oculus is also coming in
on 5 and obviously there are some stuff
isn't but like you can kind of bet on
most of the stuff coming out so that's
kind of exciting because that means that
stuff's been coming out for oculus
already like last year were people with
the headsets loads of stuff's going to
come here for that this year the
pre-orders for the vibe that means
that'll be in people's hands way before
this comes out as well which means by
the time PlayStation of your hits store
shelves or whoever they're gonna sell
this and hopefully there will be
actually quite a lot of software
available for it I want to know just be
this like horrible connect situation you
know where there's like three things to
use it for I wonder if the 400 includes
like I actually I still have a before
PlayStation Move controllers at home I
don't wonder if they throw another jail
or something yeah cuz I'll the other
ones have to have their brand new
controllers you know like yeah I've the
well I they think they have their own
names but absolute you know the circular
ones that wrap around your hand with
oculus and then the actual sticks with
the vibe there you go there's aspects
thanks so much Mary it's a LED display
five point seven inches 1080 and 120
megahertz so that is that split across
both then I wonder does that make it 60
but 60 anyway I imagine i feel the view
approximately a hundred degrees latency
less than 18 milliseconds thing that
says controller dualshock 4 and
PlayStation Move so doesn't say if it
comes with it doesn't I'm not your house
they're standing in front of a big
screen oculus doesn't come with the
controllers device that does not vibe
those 4 800 architects doesn't for 600
dad comes with an xbox one controller
comes on xbox one pad for some reason
God known forsaken yeah who knows wired
Xbox one part as well I think think yeah
there you go I wonder how many I wonder
what the final version has four USB I
will have plenty of stuff open games but
anyway to some wonder how many USB ports
at thing takes because the original
because the PS i think the PlayStation
VR has a breaker box on us ok so like
surviving slugs into yes so I mean
that's scented nitty-gritty but that'll
be the same I wonder 400 bucks like that
seems any cheaper and you're like why am
i buying this maybe is it just a piece
of crap like 400 sounds like okay it's
gonna cost him a lot of money oh here we
go final contents of the pack does not
include a playstation move controller
it's got a breakout box got the headset
yeah alright that's all the information
is there at last note on this actually
is a bit of a tangent how does a I like
head that you feels on my head it's
actually look like her than the other
ones it I haven't paid it for so long
but I've had it on for like 30 minutes a
day go on stage and I felt good Mike
what do you think of it passion for your
PlayStation is comfortable um I think
they're all pretty comfortable
relatively I think the one that I have
had most trouble with and again it's not
much is that the oculus because I it's
just I think it does feel slightly
heavier but it's also just maybe I
haven't been gotten used to it as much
but yeah place Stephen was comfortable
from the I've spent the least amount of
time with that one but I remember coming
away from PSX saying that felt really
good right yeah cuz we had it on quite a
lot Deniz oh yeah now what about
yourself or more or less the same I
didn't have it on for that long either
only have tried like one game I think a
PSX as well so it was just fine felt
fine didn't make me like oh my god on my
head you know yeah and get tight or
something it was fine cool alright well
there you go what happened just now all
right let us know whether you'll buy two
guys four hundred dollars is that feel
like a decent price for you if anyone's
actually in the comments who has just
bought a PlayStation like in the past 12
months then how does it feel to you as
well yeah what games you looking for
it's one playstation 4 if you're as well
let us know
Oh